we've left a little bit of extra time
here on this friday night and we've
gathered around some more of our team uh
to say goodbye to sally jaramillo
because after nearly five years she's
heading back to california to be closer
to her family
so this is her final uh weather cast and
we just
got together a couple of pictures of
some of the stories you've done over the
years
sally of five plus years as denise
mentioned and and on air so positive in
such a bright light but the same off air
yes really a level of positivity and
enthusiasm it just kind of comes off you
whenever you're around sally so we're
all going to miss that what you see is
what you get what you see is what you
get she's a bright light and you've
noticed that viewers at home pick that
up on the weekends as well it's been an
actual absolute pleasure to have her as
a friend as a co-anchor as a sister i'm
gonna miss you this sad music though i
know
i don't have an idea i can't hear it
for her it's not a static very excited i
love you all so much i've grown so much
with all of you guys and i've take a
little piece of my calf my denise my
brian and my sasha and all of you at
home thank you for making me sally jtv
congratulations sally good luck